we're here with the incredible vanessa
williams
um she is a judge on the new drag
singing competition series queen of the
universe
and it's time to bring out one of her
fellow judges
this show with all of its panel really
has so much expertise i'm so excited
because the contestants are going to
benefit so much and someone who knows so
much about that is ross matthew well i
do know a thing or two about judging
shows yes rupaul's drag race
and i got to see this queen rise to fame
on drag race and now she's one of the
most successful queens on the planet
please welcome the fabulous trixie
mattel
[Applause]
[Applause]
trixie this is how you show up look at
you
listen it takes a lot of confidence to
come sit next to vanilla vanessa
williams
coordinated today i agree with that well
you know there's a lot of herstory here
drag race herstory i have to say i
judged you trixie on season seven yeah
you did i want to talk to you about that
and then vanessa i judged you on
celebrity drugs celebrity drag race yes
look at you there yes there you go
and then sally vanessa
you judged trixie on all stars is that
crazy which trixie won by the way
how do you go about
saying what you need to say trixie
what's your approach i've been a
competitor and i called michelle the
week before it started and i was like
how do you judge people how do you judge
drag queens and she said think about it
they're away from their friends their
boyfriends their normal audience you as
a judge are their only lifeline to tell
them what they need to do to make it to
the end
and that made it easy because as a
competitor you want that information
yeah so you try to just tell them what
you think they need to know to snatch
the crown
there's probably terrified and you know
a thing or two about that because you
stood in front of people i mean were you
star struck when vanessa was a judge for
you are you kidding me i mean i was
starstruck then but then when i realized
i had to sit next to her every day by
the way all my gay friends are happy for
me of course they're like we're all
happy for your show vanessa
by the way you're having an anniversary
on save the best for last which is the
good lord it's a giant
yes it's the most epic song ever
it's been very good to me did you know
when you were singing that song that it
would be such an everlasting i did not
by the time i got it i heard wendy
waldman uh was playing uh wendy waldman
john lin and and phil galson wrote the
three of them and uh they had given it
to streisand she passed they had given
it to ben midler she passed so by the
time it got to me they were like okay
let's see and uh i loved it and it's one
of those things that was just a sleeper
head like it just see i love that it's
like it's meant to be yeah and then was
it true that you had a trick to sort of
um
slick your voice up so to speak it's
laced potato chips
when your voice gets tired have you
heard you've heard this i heard from you
yeah yeah when your voice i mean you're
singing a lot and your voice gets kind
of tired and the lays the grease or the
oil shall i say and the lay's potato
chips and the salt kind of makes your
voice like it brings the high end back
for reals for reals but how do you stop
eating the chips
i know or if you're not a singer
i'm sure you don't eat a chip and then
magically like
the case but this is perfect kind of
wisdom you're sharing with the
contestants on queens of the universe
right yeah i mean i don't think they
have access to chips back there but they
call them crisps and they're in corsets
and stuff they're not having chips
[Laughter]
it was nice to judge all of them because
all of those competitors are so amazing
i mean every number our jaws on the
floor are just
amazing you know you have done such an
amazing job of making a career and just
becoming this icon and i know you
actually brought something here today
that has never been seen before i did i
brought the trixie doll if you guys
would like to see it yes
okay
we know you love dogs
i do i'm so excited to see that look at
here
oh my gosh i know isn't that one look at
you
she's beautiful right can you believe
they got my real waist size
i love her it was so when i opened her
and saw her this is the first one i just
sobbed i couldn't believe it you are
priceless by the way it's cookie week on
the show if each of you would pick the
cookie that you chose to bring here that
best represents who you are as a person
i'm going to kick it off vanessa
guest my cookie boom i picked the thin
mint cookies
as my representative in a cookie why
because
why yeah because girl scouts are scrappy
they're entrepreneurial and they know
how to get it done they know how to
hustle and make it happen okay so
vanessa what's your cookie mine is uh
the molasses cookie it's saw it's brown
it should be soft and there we go sweet
with a little bit of spice just like you
waves up on you mm-hmm
[Applause]
watch out
well i have selected this lovely pink
sugar cookie isn't it gorgeous it's a
lot like me it's beautiful to look at
it's thin it's light it's filling it's
pink hey
love those i love it trixie and i love
you rossi well i thought long and hard
about this drew uh and i am a gingersnap
because
a gingerbread i have a ginger snap
that's so perfect for you thanks i took
it really seriously speaking of cookies
um i love the treats from minnie melanie
and it's a brooklyn-based company that
has made cakes for my daughters i'm so
grateful to them and they have delicious
cookies and brownies and truffles and
more and they ship nationwide and
everyone in our audience is going home
with a 50
gift card
be sure to catch the first two episodes
of queen of the universe streaming now
on paramount plus
[Music]
you